um President Biden uh president
zielinski and most of the leaders of
Europe have said that this war is likely
to end uh in a negotiation and and from
a military standpoint this is a very
very difficult fight uh this fight
stretches uh all the way from right now
so the front line goes from all the way
from car to keep down to kirison and the
significant fighting ongoing uh and it's
more or less a static front line right
this minute uh with the exception of
Bachman solidar with a significant uh
offensive action going on really from
both sides
the distance that for the United States
that's about from uh I guess Washington
DC to Atlanta so that is a significant
amount of territory and in that
territory uh are still remaining a lot
of Russian forces and Russian occupied
Ukraine so from a military standpoint I
still maintain that for this year it
would be very very difficult to
militarily eject the Russian forces from
all every inch of Ukrainian occupied or
Russian occupied Ukraine that doesn't
mean it can't happen doesn't mean it
won't happen but it'd be very very
difficult I think what can happen is a
is a continued defense stabilizing the
front I think it's possible to to
clearly do that and I think it's uh
depending on the delivery and training
of all of this equipment I do think it's
very very possible to for the ukrainians
to run a significant uh tactical or or
even operational level offensive
operation to liberate as much Ukrainian
territory as possible and then we'll
then we'll see where it goes but I do
think at the end of the day this war
like many wars in the past will end at
some sort of negotiating table and that
will be determined in terms of timing
but the leaders of both countries both
both Russia and and Ukraine uh President
Putin could end this war today it's he
started it it's his war of choice and he
could end it today uh because it's
turning into an absent catastrophe for
Russia massive amounts of casualties
lots of other damage to the Russian
military Etc uh so he should and could
in this war right now right today